[Music]
i'm distracted by this gentleman in
these shorts right here
[Applause]
you're definitely not a male model
because no guy goes like
[Applause]
check out that cat flex
oscar nominations were announced this
morning isn't that exciting
very exciting the movie lincoln received
12 oscar nominations
that's right yeah
yeah
you know what that means sequel
[Laughter]
lincoln to the lincolning
lincoln two breaking dawn
weekend at eight weekend at apes
in 3d
yeah a lot of exciting news this year
did you hear this a nine-year-old girl
was nominated for an oscar making her
the youngest nominee ever
and that's exciting nine yeah
yeah
she says she's dreamed of winning an
oscar ever since last week
president obama's inauguration coming up
just a couple days away now during next
week's inauguration president obama they
just announced will be sworn in with not
one but two bibles
he's going to be sworn in with two
bibles
i just want to take a second to say uh
just relax mr president we get it you're
not a muslim okay
you're overcompensating
two bibles and i'll dress as a priest
yeah
and michelle's dressing as a bible
it's revival
it's been reported that tickets to
president obama's inauguration are being
scalped on craigslist for two thousand
dollars
on craigslist yeah for interested send
an email to vice pres joe b at gmail
he also wants to sell a futon
[Laughter]
i couldn't believe this justin bieber is
in the news justin bieber's being sued
for allegedly beating up his
ex-bodyguard
yes
which begs the question who hires a
bodyguard that justin bieber can beat up
that's insanity
who is that guy oh no
yeah
[Applause]
everybody back
you've just done some room
a butterfly hit me
it's insanity
what else is going on new jersey
governor chris christie is on the cover
of time magazine
yeah
well some of him is
it's hard
to get all of them in there
what's going on hey and also in politics
the mayor of washington dc
says he wants the washington redskins to
change their name to something less
offensive
yeah
so they are changing it to the maryland
redskins
solution i think that's
[Music]
some mcdonald's are now replacing the
toy
that comes in a happy meal with a book
yeah
yeah the uh
the title of the book is being a kid in
2013 blows
this is weird there's a new trend of
pregnant women trying to induce labor by
having sex in the delivery room
yes
in a related story there's a new trend
of babies being born and saying good god
what the hell was that
[Applause]
i never want to see that again in my
life
got to mention this last thing this
story came out earlier this week but i
have to repeat it because it's so weird
the university of arizona now offers a
degree in hip-hop
yeah
trust me that's one class where you
don't want to cheat off the asian kid
i'm just telling you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you